yes hello my name is Jeff Goldblum and
you are buzz feed by defeat buds feeders
do you call yourselves bud buzz feed
Ian's or you've never seen me
cross-legged on the floor before except
when I when I auditioned for for waiting
for Guffman and I was the storyteller
yeah beans don't get me started about
beans yeah no I'm only kidding no
position I'd rather be in like this I
wish I had my guitar and could be
singing some some nice campfire songs
I'm gonna get some puppies in here I
love puppies
I did that movie I love dogs so I do
love dogs and Wes Anderson is a genius
and I have a dog myself and we got it
when he was a puppy
woody his name is we he's a he's a red
haired standard poodle
anyway puppies so wait wait watch these
puppies
[Music]
oh my gosh hi sweetie pie we did an
episode for this show accord the world
for Jeff Goldblum on the jewelry and I
talked to a guy and I forget where
because he was telling me about his
sweet beloved Miss Piggy his blue dog he
cremated the dog Miss Piggy and then
turned it into a jewel into a diamond a
pink diamond look all baby baby baby
deeply I'm deeply
[Music]
my fashion icons and inspiration
currently are my two sons I've got a
four year old boy named Charlie Ocean
and a 2 year old named River Joe listen
to this for Halloween River Joe I've
been showing them there's no screen time
for either of the kids but we've been
showing them little Chaplin shorts
Charlie Chaplin short subjects they love
it and the two-year-old is obsessed is
going to go for this Halloween as
Charlie Chaplin he got his outfit
yesterday for like a half an hour
couldn't stop being Charlie Chaplin I
took pictures I've got pictures right
now in my phone you cannot believe if I
could look like that and he was he
couldn't get he just kept exploring and
falling down and he had this cane anyway
he's my I'd like to look like that he's
my fashion icon the world apparent Jeff
Goldblum you know that's a character I
can relate to that's me and I'm him and
so that's that's me besides that well
look in Malcolm and Jurassic world which
I'm going to do again is these are wise
he's much smarter than I am I aspire to
his wisdom and perspective and science
but what's the name of this sweet that's
joy Julianne like Julianne Moore in in
Jurassic Park the second lost world
Julia and what's this one's name Beth
gaga gaga I love Lady gaga I love Lady
gaga
[Music]
oh yeah they say you know I'll bet no
but nobody tells you this I really liked
you ended on it out of that or it's not
something unexpected you know what they
used to do I used to go to parties this
a while ago and they would just come up
behind me and go I guess that was the
fly you know a fly joke you know mostly
you know what they do they say hey can
we can we take a picture sorry bother
you do you mind if we if I take a quick
selfie so that's what we do that's
mostly what they say yeah I said sir can
I can I get a selfie can I get a selfie
- that's what they say or I meet a lot
of them at these jazz gigs I've got this
jazz group and we meet a lot of them at
these gigs because I make myself
available which I like to do I'm very
interested in them and they and I talked
to them and we take pictures and so you
know listen that that's so interesting
that you should say that we did an
episode on makeup and it took me - we we
went to I went to this drag show
Hamburger Mary's and met them and was
very interesting in fourth grade my mom
Sharlee in Pittsburgh for Halloween
which is now a seasonal ripped from the
seasonal headlines uh she was she wanted
me to be a witch and she dressed me up
I'm telling is a really elaborate she
loved costume when she was a craft
abuser herself she made muumuus for us
and cut my hair and all did all sorts of
things but on this occasion we got a
kind of a ghoul mess but my wig and she
put her brassiere on me and stuffed it
up so I had to add a bosom and then she
put I had a little crinoline thing and
skirts and I had some ballet slippers
and I had some gloves the fingertips of
which were missing and then she put long
plastic fingernails fake fingernails on
me so I was a lady
big lady in fourth grade but I enjoyed
being masked we got because I'm a good
wife a very good boy in school in that
school what I liked best was that I was
malevolent in some way and I kind of
started to Menace and push the other
children around a little bit you know
and I like that for a time you know I
never misbehaved and it sort of access
to another part of me my drag name in
that instance was
which of Pittsburgh you know who I
admire who what my drag name now be if I
dressed up as a lady now I don't know
that I'd be an attractive lady I have to
say but right now I'd be chicken Oh Jeff
Jeff in doc Jeff Jeff and or Michelle or
you know Lucy I'm a minimalist I try to
I'd like my I aspired to wandering the
earth in a diaper and a bed with us bowl
and a spoon I that's all I want to own
real in I don't know about the diaper
part why can't I in this scenario how
come I can't find a find a bathroom I
don't to prove my fans forget it I think
that used to meit's an obsolete fantasy
at this point I do like to keep it
pruned down so glasses at different
points I've had and collected a healthy
amount of choices and currently we love
this Jacques Marie Maj designer we went
to his studio here I think all I got at
this point besides a couple are Tom Ford
blesses that we had you know a former
cycle that we've kept I don't know a
half a dozen or seven but this how you
train puppies I think you get to be hey
I'm the alpha dog here so if they can
let you do this I I met that Dog
Whisperer Cesar Millan he was lovely you
know why because I was playing a dog in
Adam resurrected I needed to be a dog so
I did my due diligence and went looking
at dogs and what are dogs and then went
to him and he said yeah you can come
over to talk to me saw his hole it's a
gang of dogs and I said how am I gonna
be a dog and why why are dogs like they
are let cetera et cetera what if I asked
you to join us like this could you
possibly join the cross Swede come on
this is the happiest moment of my whole
life
that's it if nothing happened from this
point on IBM absolutely fine
but I think I was the piano and I sang
with Brian Stokes Mitchell Mitchell who
played my husband and that and Lea
Michele was our daughter we did a scene
together I loved it I loved Wes Anderson
so any you know those sets are just I I
cannae they're just fantastic fantasy is
you know the group of the town but to
the cast and the we went to Rome to
Cinecitta and filmed a little of Life
Aquatic with Steve Zissou and then went
to Gore Vidal's villa in the south of
Italy and then for grand Budapest hotel
we went to Garland's German it was a
winter wonderland and we were all
surrounded surrounded there you know
with you know Bill Murray and everybody
was just fantastic and Nashville oh my
gosh I I'd love to go back to 1973 Nixon
resigned on television that summer and
we all were watching it together it was
a moment of jubilation and sadness
bittersweet of course for the country
but a moment of celebration and we were
all there Lily Tomlin and Keith carried
in Shelley Duvall and and Shelley Duvall
and I went to she said there's this guy
David Bowie
who's doing this Diamond Dogs tour you
know Ziggy Stardust he's gonna play live
here in Nashville lets you and I go
together we did we saw dad I delivered
and I know when I later go and work with
him so I'd revisit that set into the
night and once again be able to be with
David Bowie we had a couple of scenes
together I could do the whole thing
again you know I wouldn't mind a foot at
the end of it you just went back into
the whole thing over again I wouldn't
mind that for a moment
we went to four pools we started talking
about pools you think we'd be visiting
swimming pools we went to NASA the
neutral buoyancy lab in Houston and I
talked with astronauts who had been up
in space and met a couple of women who
were training for the new astronaut team
and they went in this pool that was so
large that they had a replica of the
space station the International Space
Station there and they were practicing
there and I went put on scuba gear and a
snorkel yeah and floated around with
them and found had many things about
space and neutral buoyancy and then a
guy who was up in the space station
currently called me and I had a talk
with an astronaut from space whoo my
dream life whoo I had dreams left last
night sometimes I don't remember it but
I know I dreamed
sometimes very very rich dreamily
sometimes I dream that that that I'm
unwelcome someplace that I'm welcome or
that I'm being chased you know around
there's some crisis and by the way I had
to dream the fresh dream that I can
remember was about a rich speaking of a
rich and she got me on a stump and she
tied me up and I thought she was gonna
cut my head off
but she all she did was she went peaches
peaches and then my brothers two older
brothers found out about it we shared a
room and at night when we all went to
bed together you know at the same time
in three different beds they would go
peaches yeah how about that
[Music]
once again I haven't been following its
I know I should but if it sounds if
everything worked out well it's as I
said in that video I had your faith in
you know all the players involved
they're they're adults and professionals
and I imagine everybody once is for the
the greatest good for the entire
community and that must include a
marriage a successful marriage and new
spider-man stories so Bravo and I'm very
happy
[Music]
hey we're we're talking about it in fact
you know I I hope so
I love ty Kauai TJ's a great director
and a friend of mine so I hope so but I
played the part again a couple of days
ago I went to the Disney Studios and I
recorded the Grand Master's voice for an
episode of a show that's gonna be on
Disney Plus called what if where it's an
animated version of all the characters
we know and love from Marvel and this
episode included the Grand Master and
Iron Man so Robert Downey will do a
voice in that and Korg Taika Waititi
will do had already recorded his voice
for that showing up I enjoyed for a
couple hours I enjoyed doing that again
so the grand master is as well all I
want you to remember if you remember
nothing else Vanderpump dogs dot-org
that is the website that you must visit
because the Vanderpump is the company
the great company that provided these
out-of-this-world adorable puppies and
we love Vanderpump Vander go to
Vanderpump dogs org that's it
[Music]
[Music]